E aí
[Música]
e ele é
curador ele é rezador
ele é chapa não ele vai me curar
esse é um trecho de um canto de uma
reverência e de um pedido de cura para
Omolú orixá e para povos de matrizes
africanas têm relação com as nossas
providências de cura para as dores Trago
essa referência porque acredito que para
falar sobre saúde é preciso reconhecer
suas diferentes concepções e a nossa
diversidade para falar sobre saúde
também é preciso compreender o impacto
da determinação social sobre a vida dos
diferentes grupos populacionais
ao longo da história a ideia de um
padrão de existência sustentado por uma
perspectiva de poder originou uma
definição única de ciência e de formas
de conhecimento o que suscitou e
normativas que se reproduzem nas e
individuais e institucionais e que se
capilarização por toda nossa estrutura
política econômica e social
a escritora nigeriana chimamanda adichie
nos faz refletir sobre o perigo de uma
história única na medida em que adoção
do padrão fomenta A negação ao direito
àqueles considerados fora das suas
prerrogativas
e quando diferentes territórios homens
negros Clamam pelo Direito de respirar e
ainda assim são sufocados até o último
suspiro pelas mãos do Estado nos
deparamos com uma estrutura geopolítica
que legitimam a violência EA violação do
direito à Vida sobretudo para a
população negra
Ah e por falar em negação de direitos é
preciso considerar que 14 de Maio para a
população negra é uma data que se
mimetiza no calendário e que nos mostra
cotidianamente os efeitos de ausência de
um planejamento social inclusivo a
população negra de têm os piores
indicadores socioeconômicos como
educação a renda e o acesso aos serviços
é quem trabalha majoritariamente na
informalidade quem está privada de
liberdade e com menor representatividade
política
esse cenário de vulnerabilidade e coroa
na condição de vida adoecimento e morte
por isso acho importante refletirmos
sobre duas questões
como assegurar o direito à saúde se os
direitos que geram Impacto direto na
saúde são violados e quem está de fato e
usufruindo do direito à saúde
a Honda história a população negra teve
o seu direito à saúde violado por meio
de práticas racistas que definiram a
hierarquiza São desse direito atribuindo
menor valor aos corpos EA vida dessas
pessoas
o e baseado nessa ordem social estudo
sobre a história da medicina revelam que
mulheres negras foram submetidas em
número de cirurgias ginecológicas
sem anestesia com intuito de
aprimoramento de técnicas e sobre a
alegação de que as mulheres negras
resistiam mais a dor
prerrogativa que sustenta a realização
de práticas obstétricas violentas até os
dias de hoje
era se ouvindo histórias marcadas por
violência e sobre os corpos negros
principalmente das mulheres negras a
minha mais velha que com três barrigas
de gêmeos se deslocou por vezes sozinha
com uma pedra na cabeça até chegar à
maternidade mais próximo porque ela
acreditava que a pedra na cabeça ajudava
assegurar à criança e de alguma forma eu
acho que ajuda o mesmo e a sua filha
seguiu experimentando violências
abandonada no corredor de um hospital
sem roupa durante o trabalho de parto
enquanto os profissionais de saúde
assistiam à final da Copa do Mundo e eu
filha da filha mesmo docente e
profissional de saúde também são corpo
negro no mundo e usuários dos serviços
de saúde e por isso não escapei e tenho
narrativas semelhante as delas
eu vi violência obstétrica quando a
médica que deveria me ajudar no parto se
recusou a me ajudar subir na maca
alegando que eu estava muito pesada o
médico que disse que o meu parto seria
de risco logo na primeira consulta sem
realizar nenhuma avaliação e ainda assim
ousou me cobrar imediatamente por uma
cesariana e mal sabe ele que eu parei
normal é importante dizer que manobras
violentas durante o parto se fizeram
presentes em todas essas histórias fruto
de teorias e práticas higienistas que
legitima o menor valor e menos cuidado
aos corpos negros
não podemos naturalizar e acreditar que
essas histórias sejam as únicas
possíveis a serem contadas por mulheres
negras No que diz respeito as suas
experiências nos serviços de saúde
Precisamos sim nos questionar sobre o
que estamos fazendo para promover
narrativas que reproduzem dor e
desamparo e dos assistência
E é difícil falar em Cuidado humanizado
se nós estabelecemos condições e
categorias de humanidade se a saúde é um
direito de todos esse ano dever do
Estado precisamos reconhecer Quem são
todos e em que condição interseccional
estão essas pessoas e Como disse agrada
kizomba a mulher negra é portanto vista
como o outro do outro
os efeitos da pandemia da covid-19
promoveram um aprofundamento do fosso
social quando comparamos os grupos
sociais atingidos a médica Jurema
Werneck enfatiza que as lentes da
pandemia ajudaram os distraídos a
enxergar a tragédia que o racismo
destacando ainda o aumento do número de
mulheres negras que vivem abaixo da
linha da pobreza
e a conjuntura evidencia né pro política
instituída pelo Estado e que tem
praticado e norteado violações sobretudo
no direito à vida e à saúde
o tom da já Mentos e práticas de cuidado
deve ser realizados por tantos conforme
em uma perspectiva da Colonial aquilo
está com a responsabilidade das
instituições formadoras de saúde não só
para discutir mas para atuar de uma
forma pro positiva No que diz respeito
ao currículo oculto que nega concepções
narrativas intelectuais e práticas de
saúde
contra-hegemônicas como as matrizes
africanas de povos indígenas e
quilombolas
subjugando assim outras formas de fazer
ciência e promoção de cuidado à saúde
negando uma formação profissional
crítica e que priorize o exercício da
Equidade No que diz respeito o Regimento
das demandas da população de acordo com
a sua necessidade conforme preconiza o
Sistema Único de Saúde
e cabe também ao gestores e
Profissionais de Saúde
questionarem se a sua formação EA
realização de sua prática na estão
dentro dessas perspectivas da coloniais
e também avaliarem se os seus
planejamentos e ações são e cones ou se
corroboram para perpetuar a ocorrência
das iniquidades
o núcleo de estudos e pesquisas em raça
gênero e saúde o negras realizou uma
pesquisa para avaliar a implementação da
política nacional de saúde integral da
população negra
uma política instituída há dez anos e
constatou que a política é uma completa
desconhecida por estes atores os quais
associam o tema saúde da população negra
somente a patologias como anemia
falciforme e Hipertensão sem atentar
para as especificidades e
o sociais dessa população
coisa resultado foi possível constatar
também o não preenchimento do requisito
raça cor nos formulários de saúde o que
nos faz deduzir que os dados não são
produzidos e nem avaliados de forma
desagregada
evidenciando o portanto a existência do
racismo institucional e promove
consequências nefastas na medida em que
as ações de planejamento de promoção da
Saúde de prevenção de doenças e agravos
são
universalizantes
desconsiderando a maioria da nossa
população a sua diversidade de
existência e de possibilidades de ser no
mundo
e os movimentos sociais quais suas ações
e com as suas tecnologias nos mostram né
que a população sabe o que quer e como
fazer para dirimir as desigualdades mas
se deparam com o silêncio daqueles que
preferem manter a perpetuação destas
desigualdades e consequentemente os seus
privilégios
e por isso é preciso também a gente
passar a discutir as desigualdades e seu
impacto na saúde sobre uma perspectiva
da branquitude Afinal nós temos um
população que tem se beneficiado com
essa conjuntura
e quanto ao estado cabe escutar as
experiências dos usuários dos movimentos
sociais e incorporá-las para que
efetivamente crie uma ambiência
favorável para a implementação de
políticas públicas assumindo assim de
fato a sua responsabilidade
As pessoas só serão saudáveis se forem
vistas e respeitadas em suas
especificidades para isso é necessário a
adoção de um planejamento e de prática
antes racistas e isso deve ser um
compromisso de todos nós na música 14 de
Maio Lazzo matumbi Jorge Portugal nos
dizem que a coisa mais certa tem que ser
a coisa mais justa
sejamos portanto agentes da justiça
social para que o direito à saúde seja
devidamente assegurado para todos para
todas e para todos é muito obrigada
E aí
[Música]